deserted streets on a monday afternoon
an unusual sight in taiwan
even more unusual people sheltering in
subway stations
but these are just drills to prepare
people for the possibility of an attack
on taiwan
i had just stopped at a traffic light
when police asked me to come to the
subway station to hide away because of
the drill
china sees taiwan as a breakaway
province and has not ruled out using
force to take the island the russian
invasion of ukraine has made taiwan more
nervous and the government has raised
its alert level
the drills are for the events that might
happen such as war so i think that these
exercises are necessary so that everyone
knows what we have to do in case there
is a situation
this year these drills coincide with
china's stern warning to the u.s about
house speaker nancy pelosi's possible
visit to taiwan
china has made it clear to the us on
many occasions that it is firmly opposed
to speaker pelosi's visit to taiwan
we are fully prepared if the u.s insists
on going its own way
china will certainly take firm and
forceful measures to safeguard its
national sovereignty and territorial
integrity
china might just be talking tough but
that statement underscores just how
sensitive the issue is and how taiwan
could be a flash point for a possible
conflict florence louis al jazeera